[Music]
this podcast has bad words
why do i feel shitty all the time
starter pack
ultra processed foods zero exercise
sitting all day
poor posture
too much caffeine
sun and nature deprived crappy sleep
social media why you gotta call me out
like that max
that's so funny that you say that a lot
of people were like i feel
you know i feel seen but also [ __ ] you
yeah right
[Laughter]
yeah let's expand on these things
that's great yeah we often feel crappy
because of ultra processed foods i mean
i think that that's the reason that's
the first thing on your list and we've
spent this maximal episode talking about
avoiding a lot of these processed foods
and refined oils and packaged foods and
the center of the supermarket etc is
there anything else to add here the the
sitting all day that's a big one we're a
sedentary
uh culture in fact we had um
um aaron aaron alexander who you've had
on your podcast too we had him on the
podcast last week and um he was talking
about movement and just doing some basic
things to get us moving again the poor
posture with too much caffeine now in my
corporate days
i was the king i probably had 20 cups of
coffee a day max i do remember you
always yeah always drinking coffee yeah
it was it was bad and so yes i felt like
crap all the time because i was
following your checklist
you were
i misread it i thought it said how to
feel great you thought it was the
opposite day
yeah no it's a big problem i mean too
much caffeine is something that like i i
have in the past struggled with and now
i'm i've brought caffeine back at the
minimal effective dose which i think is
really great because when you when
you're dependent on caffeine you're not
actually experiencing performance levels
above your baseline when you drink
caffeine you're treating your withdrawal
from caffeine and so you're just trying
to get back to your baseline levels of
performance and so that's like one to
two cups for you a day i try to do one
i do one cup a day okay and and in that
cup i've now i discovered at whole foods
actually that you can buy
half calf coffee you can band it as well
now
yeah we started doing half calf although
my wife does like 98 percent
decaf with the bandit the bandit has the
best decaf coffee there is in fact if we
have someone give it to you amazing
it is
it's a natural process it's it's
delicious but then back so she'll do 18
grams my wife will do 18 grams of
decaf and 2 grams of caffeinated in the
morning
yeah and uh yeah it works really well
for her so you found what is
optimal for you about half half
yeah because the thing is caffeine
doesn't create energy from thin air it
you're taking a loan out on your energy
levels on on later's energy levels and
you're going to repay that loan back yes
so um obviously this is a less
pronounced feeling with less caffeine so
for me yeah i took it out for a month
sometimes i'll go
even longer and i feel really great
without caffeine after a certain period
of time and then when i try that cup of
coffee i have that insane euphoric rush
that we all probably experienced with
our first cup of coffee right yeah and
then i'm like wow this is like it makes
me realize it it makes me fall back in
love with coffee and respect it as the
drug that it is i'm like wow this is a
really powerful drug which you don't
experience when you're drinking it first
thing in the morning every day right
so
yeah but that i mean that being said i
think yeah caffeine too much coffee does
make a lot of people feel
crappy um but i do love coffee so it's
about to me it's about like respecting
that relationship yeah that's a huge
takeaway for me i i didn't because i
thought caffeine was the drug that and
your body uses that caffeine for energy
but what you're saying is is that you're
basically yeah borrowing that future
energy that's a that's a pretty key
piece yeah i mean we don't feel tired
and shitty because of a caffeine deficit
right
nobody has a caffeine deficit fair
enough the messiah aren't over there in
africa like oh we the i feel better
today if we just had access to more
caffeine
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free